make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into not only the
conclusion so much as near the end of
the boys and we're covering the origin
of Billy butcher now originally I plan
on covering this earlier in the story
but as I started reading through I was
like no I want to kind of do it all at
one time I'll kind of do it in the order
that it came out because I feel like I
sort of kind of makes the story more
interesting in terms of like wrapping
back around and kind of builds mystery
over the course of everything running up
to this because it's kind of like what's
billy butcher's motivation and what's
the story behind his character right
like how you know how do we how did he
get to where he is now and become the
person that he was I felt like it was it
was kind of cool right but what this
does is this picks up in 1982 and what
was called the Falklands War right now
the Falklands War was a ten week long
conflict in the real world it was a ten
week long conflict between Argentina and
the United Kingdom and the idea behind
this was that the Falklands were
basically invaded by arjen Argentina who
really saw it as more of them taking
back lands that already belonged to them
so kind of reclaiming what the what was
rightfully theirs whereas the British
who had basically owned for like I have
a better word the Falklands territory
since 1841 saw it as Argentina invading
their territory the result is that Billy
butcher was was part and parcel to this
conflict now it wasn't a great big huge
thing and that's kind of interesting
that he wasn't really part of World War
two or Vietnam proper or anything like
that he's just part of kind of like this
this skirmish that exists out there it
only ever lasted ten weeks right but the
idea behind this is that immediately is
kind of shown right off the bat the
guy's pretty hardcore now in terms of
how this kind of unfolds we sort of end
up switching over right when he
basically you know mans a machine-gun
basically on the on the side of a what
looks like a a warship ends up taking
out this this this fighter plane
nobody end up doing is jumping to the
fact that he's basically talking to his
father who passed away and so what it
does is it jumps back to Billy butcher
as a little kid and Billy butcher was
raised in an almost sort of dr. Jekyll
mr. Hyde situation and so far that his
father was exceedingly abusive but his
mother was exceedingly nurturing right
she was a very very soft and kind person
and his father was very hard and cruel
insofar that his father actually beat on
his mother routinely and the result of
this is that it made Billy butcher tough
and rugged and the reason why was
because the desire to do something
really flew in the face of the ability
to do anything and so like a lot of
children who have been in this situation
where they were in abusive you know
abusive household his anger
an irritation manifested in other way to
I disorder if sort of drove him to act
out in other ways there weren't overly
obvious in terms of what was going on at
home right so there's one instance where
he's basically playing with a cross and
Jesus and like going on about who's
Spartacus basically and it ultimately
ends up you know when when one of the
teachers tells him to stop he tells it
off right so that of course ends up
landing him in trouble and then his
mother kind of nurtures him right
instead of providing a kind of
discipline disciplinary hand and saying
like why would you do that you know when
and punishing him instead she kind of
doesn't really say it's okay that you
did that but it's kind of like there's
other ways to deal with things this kind
of goes a little bit further as he gets
older and ends up getting into a fight
with another kid and then when the when
the PE teacher shows up to break up the
fight ultimately the kid you know he
ends up punching the PE teacher now in
this instance his father responds and
it's designed to kind of juxtapose the
way in which his mother and father dealt
with essentially similar situations
which was billy butcher acting out now
aside from putting his hands on his wife
which of course a man should never beat
his wife billy butchers father here is
not entirely wrong right he's he's not
entirely wrong here and the reason why
is because what he says is yeah I mean
you probably shouldn't have punched a PE
teacher but hey man at least you let
people know that they cannot give you a
hard time and that's kind of an
important thing to understand right
bullying is being inoculated right it's
it's inoculation for the real world that
the real world can be very harsh and
bullying teaches you not to let other
people pick on you right to stand up for
yourself and to basically give back what
other people give you and at the end of
the day if you have to choose between
being suspended from school or
self-respect you choose self-respect
because that will last you a lifetime
suspensions only ever temporary right
and so the result of this is that Billy
initially kind of takes this to its most
logical conclusion seeing his father for
what he is and seeing that the only way
his father is going to stop as if he's
removed from the equation Billy butcher
goes to get a knife with the intention
of killing him now at that point lynnie
steps in and then billy butcher ends up
back handing his brother and then seeing
his brothers face all bloody makes him
kind of draws the depiction of his
mother being bloody right so it almost
kind of throws Billy into the position
of him being his father his brother
being his mother and then father beating
on its mother and so this kind of
allegory this this sort of depiction of
how Billy sees himself in relation to
his dad drives him to stop right because
the goal is not to become his father and
that's when when Billy bins really begin
to kind of turn things around to a
degree and actually goes as far as to
join the join the military right
so that's during this this you know 10
week-long conflict and it's kind of
interesting because we thinks about this
he actually goes to visit his
grandfather and says hey like I'm
thinking about me you know join the
military and I want to get medals just
like you you know and almost kind of
romanticizes the idea of war right and
that's what most people do most people
in United States romanticized the notion
of war they watch movies like Pearl
Harbor and the big red one and tora tora
tora and Saving Private Ryan they say
wow look at that you know going overseas
of fighting bad guys or things like that
and then they get into it they get into
the thick of it and they realize just
how horrible it really is right so they
really kind of bring that sort of
torment that lifelong torment and
turmoil onto themselves by falsely
romanticizing an ideology right and so
the result of that is that that's what
billy butchers grandfather tells him you
don't want to be in war you are going to
see things that you cannot unsee for the
rest of your life it'll totally ruin you
as a human being but Billy butcher
romanticizing the idea of war ends up
joining the conflict anyway and that's
where billy butcher shows himself as
being completely different that were
wartime conflicts we're killing all
kinds of people from Argentina doing
things like like throwing a smoke
grenade and then charging an Argentine
bunker and then we're really well
they're spraying wildly into the smoke
where some of the members of his platoon
end up getting shot to pieces he just
kind of charges through right he's just
kind of like gung-ho
you know I just starts massacring people
it doesn't really affect him right even
the idea of him basically being shot and
uh potentially even dying doesn't really
affect him the way that you would expect
it to right he's not like totally
screwed up in the mind it hasn't warped
his entire perspective he doesn't suffer
from PTSD he has not fallen into a state
of depression instead he's just kind of
like these are things that I did a lot
of this I would say is a result of the
upbringing of Billy and seeing the kind
of violent environment that he was in
that while a husband beating his wife
cannot really be equated to a wartime
conflict what it did is it created a
kind of stepping stone so that once
Billy butcher got to this part of his
life that it didn't really affect him as
much as it would some kid from Heartland
America who's you know by golly always
been helping his dad with the hay and
things like that he joins the military
because it's the only way for him to get
an education you know who's totally
shielded from the world the result of
that is that when he gets back what he
ends up running into or all these guys
who are newly enlisted in the military
and in the early scene war or the
various people out there who
romanticized war and it is I tell us
more stories man tell us stories about
what it was like in in conflict and so
on Billy butcher kind of freaks out at
one point takes a glass and smash
to the mouth of another guy and then
absolutely pummels the rest of these
guys right there's all these things
where his life kind of takes this
downward spiral right being
court-martialed just these things where
he really just kind of seems to tumble
down and that's where this is his life
is just kind of falling faster and
faster seemingly out of his control
there's one point where he runs into a
bar and just says I'm gonna take out
everybody here and is up getting the
hell beat out of him it's just one thing
after another
searching for conflict searching for
trouble almost like a submission to kind
of get himself killed and this is where
he ends up running into Rebecca on a
subway train now here's something that
I'd like to have somebody explain to me
in the comment section and for those of
you guys in England what's the
difference between the subway and the
tooth what's the difference between
those two things right because in the
states oh we have our subway trains and
I mean you've got to straight like
Amtrak trains but Amtrak's
are our surface trains that take you
from one load one part of the country to
the next you know I'm pretty sure
there's trains it'll take you from like
Houston to I don't know North Richland
Hills and Texas which is probably like a
seven or eight hour drive because the
United States is colossal and that's
just in the state of Texas those are
guys who don't live in the states the
United States is insanely huge if you
drove from Los Angeles California all
the way up to Maine and let's say that
you made that drive without stopping it
would take you about 48 hours about two
straight days of non-stop driving to get
up to Maine the u.s. is huge it's insane
but if you drove from Seattle all the
way down to Key West Florida it would
take you about 51 hours right so it's
kind of that so somebody explained that
to me but he ends up coming across
Rebecca and Rebecca is this woman that
comes to him at this point in his life
when he is at his lowest point or
seemingly at his lowest point she's kind
of like this right shining star right
that's really kind of what she is at the
moment and it's a way for him to kind of
be brought back from this path of
self-destruction because that's where he
is right for example one of these
instances he basically ends up getting a
beer with her the two of them kind of
talk and and so on
and really seem to hit it off and he
says well I'm gonna go get it you know
get some more alcohol and then I'm gonna
beat the hell out of these guys and tell
them to be quiet so we can talk and the
response of Rebecca is no like don't
don't do that
just chill and there's one point where
he goes to get some more alcohol and she
says no you shouldn't drink any more
when he asked why he says yo she says
well you just told me about this
lifestyle you've been living we're even
getting into fights things like that you
know you've really kind of turned to the
drink and then you start telling me
about how your father was essentially
the same way it sounds to me like you're
becoming your dad and she really kind of
has the kind of expertise to draw these
conclusions right because she works as a
social worker so she sees this kind of
thing all the time but she's one of
these women where she really is better
for him like she's inherently good for
him because she turns she really kind of
helps to make him in and bring him back
but make him into his best self and in
reality Billy butcher starts to fall in
love and we start to see this really
kind of soft tinder version of butcher
that we haven't seen before there's one
point where it's him and it's Lenny and
his mother and it's Rebecca and they're
all gathered around that gather around
the dinner table and they're having
these conversations they're talking
about Rebecca and and so on and so forth
and it's kind of interesting right
because the father of Billy butcher has
suffered from a couple strokes up to
this point right so he's not really dead
yet but he's certainly knocking on
death's door and he's not really able to
kind of beat his wife in the way that he
has before but Rebecca really chimes in
and says that this this man that you
that you see right where you suffer from
this kind of victims mentality right
where you're not really able to bring
yourself to leave for whatever reason at
the end of the day the man that you fell
in love with is gone like he's not there
anymore there's no romance between the
two of you there's nothing for you to
say you're basically trying to catch
smoke with your hands it's not possible
the only smart thing for you to do here
is to leave and that's a huge moment
because neither Billy nor Lenny were
able to get his mother out of there but
at the end of the day there was one of
these things were what she needed was
kind of an outside factor right and she
needs somebody else to kind of come in
there and it basically steer here in
their wrist you're her in the right
direction you know somebody to say you
are not a sound mind
you're not capable of an of rational
thought on your own because if you were
you wouldn't stay here because you
cannot consciously make these decisions
on your own you need someone to steer
you towards the right decision and so at
the end of the day that's exactly what
Rebecca does and that really kind of
goes towards the idea that she's an
incredible woman from there you end up
actually having Billy and Linney and
Billy's mother and the Rebecca's showing
up on the doorstep of their apartment
and bit her basically saying I'm leaving
right you know the the mother of Billy
basically saying I'm leaving and the
father goes to kind of taunt them for a
little while
refers to to Billy's mother as a
different things like that and Billy
goes to initially launch the attack but
of course Rebecca steps in and says he's
not worth it don't become him again one
of those instances where she sort of
pulls him back from the brink and so
it's kind of interesting right because
it's one of these things where she says
you're a great man capable of great
things all you have to do is kind of
move away from this person that you have
been and try to become the best version
of yourself which is what she's been
helping him do and so ultimately the two
of them end up getting married and it's
a beautiful
because with billy butcher finding
happiness for the first real time in his
life it's at the same time yanked away
by the death of lenny and while it is
kind of a hard-hitting thing he does
have Rebekah to kind of rely on it into
sort of coaching now the reason why I
really push and really kind of rely on
Rebekah so much you really talk so much
about her is that there comes a point
where Billy and Rebecca end up going to
Miami and that's when essentially
Rebecca and Billy come across
superheroes for the first real time
right I mean we can largely assume
they've heard of them they've seen them
on TV different things like that but to
see a live in-person view of the 7 it's
something that hasn't really happened up
to this point and so the result of that
is people are of course enamored or
excited that like yeah you know
superheroes I'm getting pictures with
him different things like that and for
the most part Rebecca doesn't really
care right she's just kind of like I
mean you're the only man that I'm really
worried about right because I mean I
don't care about them like who the heck
knows what they're like you know in
their in their own time and so really
butcher ends up going for a walk and
Rebecca says she just kind of wants to
wants to sleep you know just wants to
get some rest
and so following that over the course of
the next three months or so Rebecca is
exceedingly distant right she's very
very distant she's very shut off she
doesn't really like to be touched or
anything like that she kind of wants to
be left alone now the reality is that
these are all the hallmark indications
of a woman who's a victim of sexual
assault being removed being pulled away
not wanting anybody to touch her trying
to find a sense of normalcy believe in
the world hasn't fallen apart but at the
same time not wanting to feel like she
can be so easily victimized again and so
what is up happening Billy butcher not
really knowing what's going on he ends
up hearing some kind of strange sound
that comes from next to him in the bed
turns on the light looks over and
basically this little infant is just
like ripped out of Rebecca it's just
like floating there in thin air and
probably one of the most horrifying
things that I've ever seen it starts
shooting heat vision out of its eyes
probably everything starts going nuts
right it's just like spraying stuff all
over the place you know really butcher
ends up grabbing a lamp and beats it to
death right absolutely just smashes the
damn thing and then looking over at
Rebecca Rebecca's dead it basically
ripped its way out of her and so
following that he really kind of has
this this sort of snap right bought
American steps in immediately after that
happens and they basically say this can
go one of two ways it can be the story
that you found out that your wife was
pregnant with another lovers baby and
you went insane you went into this rage
and you killed her and then cut her open
and rip the baby out you know and you
just totally lost your mind and you're
gonna spend the rest
your days in prison you know and
probably you know solitary confinement
out in Florence Colorado or you'll
probably just be given the death
sentence or you'll be thrown into a
mental institution or you can sign this
document here you're not gonna say
anything to anybody you know you're
gonna sign this document saying yes you
know you did these things that's
confession more or less and then
everything's gonna be okay right well
sweep it all under the rug and it'll all
be sorted now kind of a way for mod
American to basically remove any
involvement with regards to any of the
superheroes being involved now one thing
to understand
Billy butcher doesn't know the
superheroes are involved that's not of
what he saw with that maybe shooting
lasers out of his eyes and flying in the
air he doesn't really know of any
superhero involvement here and so I
doubt his calm as a cucumber he asked
this guy he says you're married and the
guy says yes and he says you imagine
what it's like to know that you're never
going to see her again and then gouges
this guy's eyes out of his head he hopes
this broad American representative
understand his place in the bigger
picture and so following that Billy
butcher is like just absolutely has the
hell beat out of him
and then he's kind of left there and
then suddenly here comes Gregg Mallory
now Mallory of course as you guys know
was the guy who originally formed the
boys team and showing up here - Billy
butcher notice this it's not really like
it was with Huey right Billy Butcher was
capitalizing on Huey struggle and saying
hey man like we got a mission to carry
out and that kind of stuff and almost
kind of manipulating Huey in in a few
different ways when it comes to Gregg
Mallory it's not really like that it's
yes he's sort of sort of using this this
kind of anger that Billy butcher has but
what he says is I can promise you
vengeance against the person that's
responsible for this but before any of
that happens he basically says this is
your wife's diary you know you didn't
know about it and Billy butcher even
goes as far as to say I didn't know my
wife didn't have a didn't have a diary
but basically you know this is neo Gregg
Mallory says here's your wife's diary
read through it and then in turn let me
know what it is that you want to do and
reading through this diary Billy butcher
comes to the realization that when they
were in Miami and he had gone for a walk
that the home Lander had shown up in
their room and then basically heard
during the night and the wind when when
he got back when Billy butcher got back
you know she prayed that Billy what you
would never find out about it because
she knew he would go after home Lander
and get himself killed she essentially
kept it all to herself and that's why
she ended up dying because she was by
home Lander in response Billy butcher
loses his mind and he's just like open
the door right he just totally freaks
out right and immediately goes - Gregg
Mallory and Gregg Mallory says if you
side with
me it might take years it might take
decades but I promise you we will get
the homeland er you'll get your revenge
we'll bring that whole system down
around and the responsibility butcher is
I'm in done and so from there Mallory
basically says I need you to do
everything that I tell you to do and
with their first mission he basically
gives them this assault rifle and says I
need you to go into that house and I
need you to kill everyone you can find
and let me tell you guys something
that's Lancelot it was judgement day in
this house bootie butcher goes running
in here with this machine gun and
without even saying a word sprays down
everybody one of the guys is bulletproof
building butchered figures out the guy's
eyes aren't bulletproof shoots him in
the eye and then puts a gun in his mouth
and then shoots them through the head
and basically goes through and execute
every last one of these guys he doesn't
say a word he doesn't say anything to
anyone he just goes through and shoots
them all doesn't answer any questions no
nothing leaves the gun there leaves the
casings there goes into the car with
Gregg Mallory basically says I assume
you were trying to send a message so I
left the gun and the casings they pour a
cup of coffee and they ride off and
that's how things go for the next little
while right for the next few years it's
basically this idea of them traveling
through and either taking out and
killing superheroes or using them to get
information and that's that's literally
how this whole system works right so
they come across the legend the legend
starts feeding them information
basically saying here's how these
various things unfold that's where
things kind of get bonkers this is how
the boys group ends up forming and so
that's when we kind of cut back to Billy
butcher basically having this
conversation with his with his father's
corpse and saying like I've made
different mistakes over the course of my
life when I write me I've made mistakes
I've done bad things but I've also
fallen in love I fell in love with the
greatest of women that I'd ever met and
ultimately lost her and basically what
Billy butcher tells his father is when I
was younger I had your anger in your
wrath in me right I didn't want to have
children with Rebecca because I didn't
want to pass that on but what I've
learned is your vindictiveness that's
all part of me it's impossible for me to
get away from that right that's who I am
and so if that is who I am then why not
use it but I will say this he's like at
the end of the day I never did the kind
of things that you did and never laid a
hand on my wife I never abused the
people closest to me and instead of
doing what you did and lashing out of
people and compensating for your
weakness I am a legit tough guy right I
fought in wars I've allowed myself to
live and allowed myself to love and I'm
gonna go forward doing the same thing
that I've always done and I'm gonna take
out all these superheroes and then I'm
gonna get my revenge and then I'm gonna
kill homeland err and so it's kind of
his
last goodbye to his father he stands up
whips his gal and pisses all over his
head with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
please okay I want to give a shout out
to Kyle be David Joseph then john h aj
matt in jeff are John H lean and mean
which is an awesome name Jason see
Austin s Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin
be Adam K and Genesis 9 16 you remember
guys you could send me messages and I'll
run off whatever your message is at the
end of the video so long there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shout outs then I
will tack it in there and yeah they
should watch you guys
[Music]
you